Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Rachel, Kevin, Sarah. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
Recommendation five: shared outcome over individual optics. I'll name my own pattern and then get out of the way — last quarter I sequenced the roadmap for fundraiser optics over what actually de-risked the work.
Rachel, if I do it again in Q4, call it in the room.
Wait — before you move on, can you go back one slide?
Sure — one sec.
Just flagging that this touches the CARE governance framework, so loop me in when it firms up.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Agreed, let's capture it.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Deal. The concrete version: the needs board ships when it's actually useful to a teacher, not when it demos best for a slide. I'd rather show a rough thing that works than a polished thing that doesn't.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Right, that's what I meant.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with district partnerships.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Sure, I can own that.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with district partnerships.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the access needs-board and credits broker.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
How does this interact with the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, if at all?
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
That's fair.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Agreed, let's capture it.
Yeah.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with district partnerships.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Yeah, exactly.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
The districts I talk to care whether it works, not how the pitch looks. When we optimize for the demo we're optimizing for the wrong audience — the funders are a means, the classrooms are the point.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Okay, works for me.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Good point — let's do that.
Hmm, okay.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Makes sense to me.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
So here's the decision rule I'd propose we adopt: when optics and outcome conflict, we write down which one we chose and why. That makes the tradeoff visible in the record instead of defaulting to optics silently.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Let me park that and come back to it.
Bear with me, I'm going to pull up the schema real quick.
I like that it's a paper trail, not a vibe. If we choose optics for a real reason — say a funder deadline — that's fine, but we said so on purpose.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Right, that's what I meant.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Let's confirm in the channel.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
That's fair.
And it gives me something honest to tell the districts about where they are in the queue.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
How does this interact with the access needs-board and credits broker, if at all?
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Sorry, can you say that last part again? You cut out for a second.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Right, that's what I meant.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Sure — one sec.
Anyone object to making that the standard for Q4 planning?
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Good point — let's do that.
No — it's the same principle as publishing our before/after openly. The win belongs to the mission, not to any one of us.
How does this interact with the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, if at all?
Yeah, exactly.
Right, right.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Just flagging that this touches the access needs-board and credits broker, so loop me in when it firms up.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Yeah, exactly.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Makes sense to me.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync anyway.
That's fair.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Just flagging that this touches the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, so loop me in when it firms up.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Yeah, exactly.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Right, that's what I meant.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Okay, works for me.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Agreed, let's capture it.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the access needs-board and credits broker.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Makes sense to me.
Right, that's what I meant.
That's fair.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Okay, works for me.
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
Quick clarifier — who owns the follow-up here, and by when?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
One thing: how does this affect the district partnerships timeline?
Quick clarifier — who owns the follow-up here, and by when?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Dana has the follow-up on the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Rachel has the follow-up on the access needs-board and credits broker — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Kevin has the follow-up on district partnerships — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.